[Music]
shelley's going to start off this hour
in florida hi shelly how are you
good how are you better than i deserve
what's up
well i'm calling to get your advice
about whether i should insist that my
husband carry
health insurance he feels like it's a
violation of his faith in god
um to carry insurance basically he feels
like he gave his life to christ and
you don't insure what you don't own
we've been married 10 years we're both
widowed and
we each have a high relative net worth
when we were first married he didn't
have any health or property insurance
most of his net worth was tied up into
18-acre property which he opened up for
church retreats and people to have
weddings which you know would open him
to a lot of
liability hurricanes but he you know
always insisted that his faith and
his money came from god and he feels
like it's a violation
and so i added him reluctantly onto my
insurance
when he we first got married and now
we've recently re
retired and he doesn't want to carry
health insurance
and i feel like at 60 my first husband
died of lung cancer so it makes me a
little
uncertain and fearful for someone to go
without health insurance
so i'm calling in to see what you think
[Music]
well this man obviously loves god
a lot and um is
really really trying to walk out his
faith in a very dramatic way
um and i doubt seriously that anything
that john or i say will change his mind
i think he's been living and thinking
this way for a very very long time
um i have health insurance and i'm a
christian and it doesn't diminish my
faith
it doesn't mean that i don't trust god
but it does mean that i am
i also i don't know i mean
there's a lot of bizarre examples you
could come up with of other things that
he probably does but that also violates
what he's talking about
that's the problem with getting jot and
tittle oriented
um is that you end up stepping on one of
the jots or the tittles
i like thinking of health insurance as a
way to honor my family
and honor those who will be left paying
medical bills if i pass away those who
are trying to grind out and figure out
what to do while i'm sick or
incapacitated and it has
less of a of a kind of calling
god's bluff if you will or or putting
god to the test for this is the way this
is going to happen let me tell you
another one okay
here's one that comes up that i hear
i've heard this i've heard this one more
often than yours
shelly um i don't save money
because god says he will take care of me
he says not to worry because if the
sparrow falls from the air he knows that
he knows the number of hairs on your
head
and so as an act of faith i don't save
money and yet that is inconsistent with
scripture
because in proverbs which is also god's
word
it says to uh in the house of the wise
are stores of choice food and oil
but a foolish man devours all he has so
when you say i don't save money as an
act of faith
the bible says you're foolish that
you're not
wise by the way foolish is a fool in
action
that means you're a fool okay if you
don't save money that's what the bible
says
now don't get mad at me god said it so
um
but but you know and the mind of man
plans his ways and directs his steps
jesus said don't build a tower without
first counting the cost
lest you get halfway up and you're
unable to finish and all who see you
begin to mock you
and say this man began to build and was
unable to finish
all of these are indicators and there's
scripture after scripture after
scripture after scripture
that god is a god of order a god of
planning and uh the farmer doesn't walk
out to the field and say
um grow crops
because i have faith in god god says
farmer put
seed in the ground and that gives you
the crop after god brings the rain and
the sun
and i gave you the original dirt to
start with so we can honor god
without provoking him
and i i think your husband has a
wonderful heart um
i disagree with his conclusion but i
also doubt
that i can say anything or john can say
anything that'll change his mind
i agree with john though it is it's
making you squirrely it's making you
nervous and i don't blame you
um and as a way to honor his wife as a
way to say i'm a caretaker i'm
going to be good to my family my job is
to serve my family to be a good
manager here's a way of looking at it
another way of looking at it and thought
about this
just making this up on there as i go i
do that every day and
um we try to keep up with you uh
uh god says to be a good manager
if you had a manager running a business
and refused to buy insurance
when he could transfer some of the risk
around associated with the business all
right
i don't think i would call that guy a
good manager right if i had a a branch
somewhere i don't but if i had a branch
with a building and i found out the
manager refused to carry
him and he says well you know it's god's
building if it burns it's god's will
and god will take care of us and he said
that i would fire him
right for being an incompetent manager
there's that old story
um it's an old parable and it's silly
but um of some shape form or fashion
about
the it rained real hard and the the
flood rains the flood waters were coming
up and the guy standing on the roof
right
um and he sends a boat he doesn't take
it
home he's gonna come get me then send a
helicopter god's gonna come get me
and then he drowns and goes to heaven
said god where were you he's like dude i
should i sent a boat i said to
helicopter what are you doing
and so yeah it's this idea um you know a
few years ago
i heard a great speaker talking about
going to visit the um
the atrocities in rwanda and a
extraordinary minister said i've stopped
asking the question where's god
and i've started asking the question
where are god's people and
they are the action and they are the
breath and they are the
hands um dealing with all the nonsense
on this earth
and so yeah i like to go back and say um
man you're gonna pass away and say i i
gave you a plan to help pay for that
that that lung insurance parable the
talents i told you to manage this well
and you didn't manage it well so i'm
gonna take it away from you that's right
yeah and then you're gonna call that
god's will well it was god's will he
took it away from a bad manager all
right
so i i um again all i like to say is i
like to answer these kind of questions
with what i do in my house i have health
insurance for me and my family yeah
me too and all of our team here so if
you want what my opinion is what i do
for my kid does that
be inconsistent i do understand
the struggle that he has the faith it is
when i first came to faith as an adult
i was trying i was straining so hard i
really wanted to be what god wanted me
to be in every area
even if other people didn't understand
even if even if none of the rest of
society did i didn't care
that one guy i need to take to be happy
and that was jesus what am i
you know what do you want me to do god
what do you want me to do with this and
i did some stupid butt stuff
in the name of my newfound faith at the
time now this guy is not new
right he's been doing it a long time but
i can tell you this i was that guy
there's a part of me that relates to him
and he's a good man
and he loves god he's not he's not a
crazy man right um he's just come up
with
a couple crazy conclusions disagree with
him but i think you've married a good
man probably i think he's a kind man